alors on commence cette page de sport
avec du sport et un des invités Olivier
sevesuc vous êtes président de l'AS
Poissy qui connaît des difficultés
Nicolas effectivement d'origine
intentionnaire de la nationale de l'AS
Poissy et sous la menace d'une
relégation en régionale une en cause une
dette qui s'élève à plus de 250 000 €,
une décision rendue par la direction
nationale du contrôle de gestion de la
Ligue professionnelle de football alors
première question Olivier est-ce que est
en danger pour sa survie écoutez la
survie d'un club étant en danger pour
rester au niveau de National 2 cela va
faire 6 ans que je suis président adapt
c'est la première fois que je suis
confronté à ce problème là mais c'est
vrai que entre
je veux dire les les différentes
réunions que je peux avoir formelles ou
informelle avec monsieur carloli le
député qui m'a nommé il y a 6 ans et
Madame le Maire et ses services on
essaye de trouver ensemble la meilleure
solution pour savoir comment
on peut à terme sauver cette équipe de
national de cependant vous savez un club
si on n'est pas en National 2 on peut
être National 3 l'as Poissy existera
toujours qu'elle soit nationale 2 en
National 3 ou R1 aujourd'hui la question
qu'on peut se poser comme on est arrivé
là on avait déjà alerté et j'avais déjà
alerté on était déjà sur un déficit de
150000 euros on a malheureusement
en tant que président avec mon trésorier
et le bureau
u un certain nombre de problèmes
d'ailleurs on s'en était expliqué ici
sur le plateau de mémoire c'est pas la
première fois je viens vous voir des
problèmes de licence 34000 euros des
sponsors perdus
ça va très très vite donc la spirale va
très vite il s'avère que voilà on avait
des contrats sur des joueurs qui n'ont
pas étonné par d'autres clubs je vais
citer personne je crois qu'on n'est pas
là et je suis pas là ce soir pour régler
des comptes bien au contraire je suis là
et vous connaissez mon engagement et les
gens qui travaillent avec moi le savent
je le fais bénévolement évidemment j'ai
donné beaucoup de temps comme me dit
Monsieur car le livre et qu'il écrit
d'ailleurs j'ai servi club peut-être que
de certains sont servis à d'autres fins
moi non maintenant l'idée c'est de se
dire qu'est-ce que l'on fait il y a des
emplois il y a des joueurs puisque ce
statut de N2 et vous le savez très bien
c'est l'amateurisme d'un côté les faits
des roues de l'autre on a on a toujours
été entre guillemets entre deux pour
être vulgaire un peu bâtard parce que on
sait pas trop se positionner et c'est la
difficulté d'être un ANC j'ai si vous
êtes en M3 ou en R1 vous n'avez pas
cette DNCG donc on m'avait fait des
recommandations mais après j'ai toujours
eu l'espérance je suis dans l'espérance
vous me connaissez vous connaissez mes
origines ukrainiennes j'ai toujours été
dans l'espérance de me dire un jour ça
va s'arranger malheureusement les
sponsors qui m'avaient promis et vous
savez les amis dans ce monde là quand on
s'y ni rien vous devez connaître
messieurs aussi autour de la table vous
êtes dans le monde du sport non pas tenu
leur promesse maintenant je règle aucun
compte ce soir alors l'espoir c'est
demain c'est cette réunion à la mairie
de Poissy qu'est-ce qui va se passer
durant cette réunion sur l'initiative de
Monsieur carlolive et Madame le Maire
l'idée c'est de mettre
de 250 000 je n'avais pas perdu ces
choses qui ne sont pas de mon faites on
serait à -100 000 - 100 000 comme je
l'ai dit aussi à qui de droit quand
l'État français est à 3000 milliards de
dates ou certains clubs je pense que ça
aurait fait peut-être 100000 de déficits
ça serait pas énorme aujourd'hui c'est
juste pour éclairer un peu tout le monde
sur la situation surtout par régler de
compte c'est pas mon style mais de dire
on a peut-être fait des erreurs la
confiance les prix aussi un certain
nombre de choses cette équipe a tourné
n'oubliez pas on était premier à une
époque avant cette malheureusement cette
bêtise qu'il y a eu les 7 points perdus
ah oui mais c'est point c'est rien c'est
pas de l'argent mais c'est les 34000 qui
ont derrière philosophie du mal en plus
du reste et il s'avère que demain on va
l'expliquer en toute honnêteté moi j'ai
aucun problème vous savez quand on est
bénévole comme moi et qu'on a mis du
temps de l'argent parce que le président
de club amateur aujourd'hui enfin on va
dire entre deux c'est presque un
sacerdoce c'est c'est faire des nœuds au
cerveau mais croyez-moi je m'en fais et
c'est dommage parce que mais il y a des
emplois à sauver pour la pérennité du
club j'espère que voilà j'ai des
investisseurs j'ai deux dossiers à
présenter ça passe ou ça casse parce que
aussi les gens vous promettent ne
tiennent pas toujours leurs engagements
on en serait peut-être pas là
aujourd'hui mais on va voir comment les
choses s'orientent moi en tout cas je me
borde normal juridiquement et à partir
du moment où il y a pas le mal forcément
pardon malversation je suis pas très
inquiet pour le club pour lequel je suis
intéressé tout Nicolas vous avez un mot
sur le volet sportif
jouer la 30e et dernière journée de
National 2 et lourde défaite à
l'extérieur face à l'équipe de du Stade
Rennais 6 buts à zéro les picia qui
termine à la sixième place au classement
alors certes des problèmes et des
difficultés financières mais sixième du
classement comment se sente justement
les joueurs alors une lourde défaite 6-0
ils avaient peut-être pas la tête à
jouer au football ce week-end vous savez
ça encore c'est la difficulté quand on
part en déplacement nous n'aurons pas
toujours les moyens d'avoir comme des
clubs professionnels des cas on a essayé
ça coûte une certaine somme on essaie
d'avoir des partenaires
de les arrêter à l'hôtel il y a quelques
années avec il y a deux trois six ans
maintenant on pouvait faire une sieste
on essayait de trouver un groupe en
l'occurrence je vais pas le citer mais
voilà il aurait pu être notre partenaire
il l'est pas parce qu'ils ont des
problèmes aussi on s'arrêtait dans un
dans un hôtel restaurant il faisait une
petite sieste à trois dans une chambre
on avait un statut quand vous partez en
minibus à Rennes à 7h du matin pas de
sieste et là c'est sandwich puisque j'ai
dit on a plus les moyens aujourd'hui
comme on voulait faire un résultat comme
vous ne savez pas si vous aurez vos
salaires comme je ne sais pas si vos
réseaux frais c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui cette défaite finalement
c'est la résultante on était et sixième
avec ses problèmes là moi je félicite
tout le groupe le staff les joueurs
c'était une année fantastique moi j'y
suis pas allé je fais tous les
déplacements depuis 6 ans quand je peux
mais ils ont fait 80%, vous allez
montrer ce que j'ose même pas parler à
mes joueurs pour vous dire j'ai quelques
joueurs au téléphone mais quand on sait
pas quoi leur dire Président on en est
où
je suis malade quoi en fait leur avenir
à eux aussi est-ce que il y en a
certains qui vous ont dit on part on
sait l'attachement de votre coach actuel
au club aussi bien sûr ils veulent
partir où finalement ils vont rester ils
vont se battre avec vous à vos côtés ils
se sont battus parce que aujourd'hui il
y a aucune fronde c'est ça qui est assez
extraordinaire c'est que j'ai eu des
garçons au téléphone qui me disent
président il y a des clubs qui parce que
avec les bonnes prestations qu'on peut
faire les uns et les autres évidemment
il y a des clubs soit dans la région ou
même en France qu'on vu leur prestations
à un moment donné l'équipe de Poissy
fonctionnait très bien d'ailleurs on
était deuxième on a battu Rouen qui
monte une fois chez nous une fois chez
eux et ça prouve la qualité de mon
équipe du staff et et tous les joueurs
donc je leur dis je sais pas quoi vous
dire aujourd'hui je suis pendu à la dmcg
c'est quoi la suite justement par la
DNCG je les appelais en disant c'est
très très dur on est l'appel sera
entendu le 4 juillet quand on s'est
préparé une saison l'année d'avant je la
préparais là aujourd'hui demain près de
main c'est très compliqué qu'est-ce que
je vais dire aux joueurs il y a encore
des salaires à payer au mois de juin à
ce jour je ne sais pas si je pourrais
les honorer est-ce qu'on va faire
une liquidation judiciaire je voudrais
pas en arriver là ça serait trop dommage
est-ce que des gens vont se mobiliser je
suis presque envie vous voyez comme j'ai
fait pour les Ukrainiens de dire je suis
tellement mobilisé pour pour mes cousins
on va dire pour mes frères quand j'ai
fait cette quête j'ai eu un peu d'argent
j'ai envie de dire les gens qui sont
amoureux de Poissy c'est pas moi c'est
pas mon avenir je suis prêt à laisser le
club pour sauver le club je le laisse
j'ai dit à tout le monde j'ai pas
d'avenir personnel j'étais 10 ans
président du nid on connaît mon
application ma médaille de mérite pour
ça tout ce que j'ai pu faire chez mes
amis SOS Racisme juste avant d'arriver
là qui m'ont appelé tout à l'heure
vice-président mais tout ce que tu as
fait de toute façon il faut pas te
rendre malade il faut dire des vérités
et je le dis avec mon cœur d'ailleurs
j'étais quand même
oui un peu ému que Carl dit ces mots sur
moi et encore ce matin par téléphone en
disant mais tu as rien à te reprocher
quelques erreurs on en fait parce qu'on
a envie quand on est président comme moi
qu'on est qu'on est toujours auprès de
ses joueurs que cette adrénaline dans le
vestiaire j'ai quand même été joueur et
un joueur qui a joué aussi au niveau
entre guillemets national toute ma
carrière pratiquement voilà quoi ce
sentir comme ça pas abandonné parce que
personne m'a abandonné néanmoins je
pense que vous me poserez la question le
PSG arrive alors justement le Paris
Saint-Germain qui arrive au campus cet
été ils vont s'installer l'équipe
l'équipe va jouer
juste en face de chez vous c'est le PSG
vous avez eu des contacts avec eux vous
avez fait une lettre au Président
je sentais déjà que c'était compliqué
sans lui demander de l'argent déjà le
lui dire que j'ai joué par Paris
Saint-Germain j'ai porté les couleurs et
que j'adore ce club que j'ai trois
abonnements depuis 30 ans que c'est mon
club et que voilà bienvenue mais je
voulais lui dire aussi si on pouvait se
rencontrer vous avez envie de donner
votre amour je l'ai toujours donné aux
autres toute façon c'est ma conviction
c'est que partage mais voilà même je
comprends d'autres chats fouetter que
l'AS Poissy néanmoins c'est vrai que
j'aurais bien voulu participer avoir des
joueurs de chez eux des jeunes je rêvais
un certain nombre de choses ce qui est
normal je suis président et même pour
mes jeunes après écoutez vous savez moi
je suis voilà je suis croyant j'ai la
foi j'ai bienveillance pour les autres
et je crois qu'un jour peut-être que les
choses vont évoluer en toute humilité
j'y crois un peu encore il faut être
dans l'espérance toujours les derniers
mots merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation